eso es cierto que durante las últimas
décadas en varias
países del Mundo han existido
movimientos en contra de la monarquía
británica obviamente y envolverse
en una República pero yo creo que la la
Reina Isabel la segunda fue una una
persona con un gran sentido de humor por
ejemplo seguramente todos nosotros vimos
la reina con con James bonds Durante los
Juegos Olímpicos en el 2012 en Londres
Pero había había muchos episodios en los
cuales la reina
mostró mostraba su gran sentido de humor
su corazón podía conectar con la gente y
yo cree que ella podía conectar con la
gente tanto no solamente por
mostrarse la simpatía empatía por la
gente Saludos todo el mundo de muchos
diferentes culturas sino también por su
ética de trabajo que siempre trabajar y
ella Realmente está muy muy poco a
principio de esta semana
ministro de Reino Unido y con letras la
nueva primera ministra de Reino Unido Es
realmente la vida de Isabella fue una
diaria entregar esa revisión y de
muchísimo trabajo
señor zen siguiendo con este tema además
de haber contado con esa gran
popularidad dentro de la gente de la
Reina Isabel segunda está al frente de
un país con mucha vegetación política
hablando del tema político por ejemplo
listras acaba de llegar a ser al
gobierno como nueva primera ministra del
Reino Unido la cuarta en los más
recientes años además por el partido
conservador ella también ha sabido supo
ser un equilibrio de poderes a nivel
político en medio de un país con una
gran división gran polarización y con
muchísima agitación política
Sí exactamente una una de las reglas muy
importantes de la monarquía británica es
exactamente eso no meterse públicamente
por lo menos no meterse en en política
no opinar por ejemplo sobre temas como
el brexit sobre el tema como el tema
energético como el temas de la
posibilidad de de una independencia de
Escocia o temas como
Irlanda del Norte durante las últimas
décadas Estos son temas muy muy muy muy
muy difíciles y la reina siempre ha
mantenido esta postura que sea muy
objetiva y neutral y obviamente al mismo
tiempo ella siempre
se reunía con los primeros nuestros
colombianos una vez a la semana en su
Palacio para la gran mayoría en el
Palacio de buckingham luego luego y
durante sus vacaciones por ejemplo
en Escocia también entonces ella siempre
tenía este contacto muy cercana al pulso
de la de la política británica pero no
solamente la de la política británica
sino también por la historia del imperio
británico
con muchas partes del mundo en África en
Asia en Australia y otros países del
mundo Entonces es una una persona muy
muy involucrada política pero al mismo
tiempo muy neutra